[Musique]
le séjour du retour
alors à vegas optima plissées et fumer
sa clope pour la famille wilpon et puis
en même temps c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut le raconter on va faire
différemment
oh
[Musique]
mon soutien
et le rêve est devenu réalité grâce à
atari les jeux pour quel jeu joue et
quand j'étais gamin on les a en vrai
avec l'atari kong
pour tous les amateurs ping pong au port
s'entraîner tout seul et le champion du
monde juste dingue
[Musique]
non
c'est stevie wonder
là
[Musique]
non
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc on va
aller voir ça directement
[Musique]
on demande bien pourquoi nous ont collé
un miroir là le camping car le plus cher
du monde
vous avez que les cuisines de fous
furieux le petit canapé à la cool ça
c'est quand même un truc de dingue
l'hélico sur mon camping car tu avais
pas pensé avant mais maintenant vous le
dit jacques leplat
[Musique]
on continue
au manoir
fanny beaumont face
oui
oh
[Musique]
tout va bien tout est normal
on érige les gas et des gens qui plonge
dans des forums d énorme poisson ici
c'est un centre commercial avec une
fontaine de ouf des magasins de ouf
apple store que des trucs hyper hyper
cherves sin city la ville du péché tu
m'étonnes cdma la ds qui use c'est quand
même une fausse ville tu te balades
regarde la tronche
pas vraiment l'impression d'être dans
une
ouais mon un truc de fou maintenant le
but c'est de trouver la sortie
je suis perdue et j'ai même trouvé un
truc incroyable une boutique avec une
boutique spéciale céline dion avec les
shops les mugs les valises les cds
céline dion tous ces mondiaux
watts et du boeuf séché il devance à 10
dollars le branchement
je prends envie de manger
les taux viennent de sauter qui a rendu
c es black out des problèmes d'accès en
courant comme ça c'est quoi
plus alarmant pour les smartphones
servir donc là on est au casino de
l'hôtel de vnpt et deviennent énormes
hotel and casino
il ya des machines de partout serdioukov
c'est calme j'étais hier soir pour
bosser là je vais me trouver une petite
prise électrique pour pouvoir bosser et
l'internet gratuit
c'est compliqué tu as réussi parce que
quand tu veux te prendre un abonnement
par être connecté à internet aux crs tu
peux soit c'est gratuite à une demi
heure mais mois pour envoyer les vidéos
c'est largement pas suffisant soit un
truc payant ses 79 dollars par jour font
pas l'amour à l'haïtien donc l'idée là
c'est de se trouver une petite prise
électrique de ce câble et parce que j'ai
plein de vidéos à vous envoyer et que
comme je vous ai déjà dit rouergue bien
de virer c'est une brigade
regardez moi toutes ces machines c'est
vraiment eu de soucis
tu peux jouer à toute heure du jour de
la nuit papa de losail à claquer ici je
te dire tu peux y aller c'est open bar
c'est vraiment un truc de fou
[Musique]
pas
c'est vraiment trop cool ce truc c'est
incroyable les sensations sont folles on
y est quoi la vr c'est génial là dans le
truc c'est vraiment de l'annonciation
extrême je sais pas si un jour ce truc
on pourra le trouver dans des endroits
on pouvoir le frère si vous avez
l'occasion en vr c'est comme être dans
un espèce de grand huit ans rires je
sais que ça existe et ça je n'avais
jamais fait c'est vraiment génial c'est
la grande éclate
décidément ce c es tout ce qu'on y
trouve
on découvre tout ce contexte c'est de la
pure folie
[Musique]
m
s
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]